.
Gut, Freunde der Sonne, kommen
wir endlich mal zu einer
der am häufigsten gestellten Fragen
in unseren Kommentaren,
nämlich, wie schlimm ist Süßstoff?
Etwas, das super süß schmeckt
aber null Kalorien hat
ist manchen schon
an sich suspekt.
Dann hört man immer wieder,
dass Süßstoff Heißhunger,
Übergewicht, Diabetes Typ 2
auslösen soll,
also all das, was man eben nicht
will, wenn man zu Cola light greift.
Sind Aspartam, Saccharin
und Co. wirklich so schlimm?
Die kurze Antwort ist:
Ja und Nein.
Und die lange Antwort,
die gibt es jetzt.
Erst mal die Basics:
Süßstoffe sollen ja Zucker
ersetzen, denn eine zuckerreiche
Ernährung erhöht das Risiko für
Übergewicht, Diabetes Typ zwei
und Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen.
Aber, Zucker ersetzen
ist gar nicht so einfach.
Zunächst schmeckt uns
Zucker einfach sehr gut
und der Geschmack von Süßstoff
kommt da einfach nicht dran.
Lebensmittelhersteller haben wenig
Anreize, den Zuckergehalt zu senken.
Zucker ist fast überall zugesetzt,
als billiger Geschmacksverstärker.
Außerdem hat Zucker, neben
der Süße, auch noch wichtige
physikalisch-chemische Eigenschaften
für Lebensmittel.
Bei Eiscreme gilt z.B.,
je weniger Zucker,
desto härter und
uncremiger das Eis.
Auch Gebäck oder Kuchen wird
trocken, wenn man Zucker reduziert.
Deshalb gibt es auch eine ganze
Reihe an Süßstoffen
mit verschiedenen Süßegeraden,
aber auch mit verschiedenen
physikalisch-chemischen
Eigenschaften, um nicht nur
die Süße des Zuckers, sondern
auch das gesamte Mouthfeel
zu kompensieren,
wie man so schön sagt.
Dann gibt es immer wieder
Schlagzeilen, dass Süßstoffe
wie Aspartam oder Saccharin
Krebs auslösen können,
aber für diese Sorgen
gibt es keine belastbaren Daten.
Die Sorgen beruhen zwar auf
wissenschaftlicher Forschung,
die allerdings vorschnell
interpretiert wurde.
Nach Warnsignalen aus Tierversuchen
oder einzelnen Studien
stellten ausführliche Studien
keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen Süßstoffen und Krebs an
Menschen fest.
O. K., Vor Krebs muss man bei
Süßstoffen also keine Angst haben,
aber die anderen Sorgen, die
sollten wir uns genauer anschauen.
Doch dafür müssen
wir erst verstehen:
Süßstoffe sind Moleküle, die,
genau wie Zuckermoleküle,
an die süß-Rezeptoren
auf unserer Zunge binden,
und dann das Signal süß
an unser Gehirn weitergeben.
Da sie besonders stark mit den
Rezeptoren wechselwirken,
sind Süßstoffe besonders süß.
Süßer als Zucker.
Doch abgesehen von den
süß-Rezeptoren auf der Zunge
kann der Rest des Körpers mit
vielen Süßstoffen nichts anfangen,
denn sie werden nicht
verstoffwechselt.
Man sagt, sie sind inert,
das bedeutet,
sie beteiligen sich nicht
an chemischen Reaktionen.
Sie passieren unbeteiligt, inert,
den Körper.
Wenn keine chemischen Reaktionen mit
dem Süßstoff-Molekül stattfinden,
dann kann aus diesem Molekül auch
keine Energie gewonnen werden.
Deshalb haben Süßstoffe wie
Aspartam, Saccharin, Cyclamat,
Sucralose, auch keine Kalorien.
Es gibt auch Süßstoffe,
die verstoffwechselt werden
und damit auch Kalorien haben,
dazu zählen die Zucker-Alkohole,
also Sorbit, Xylit, Maltit usw.
Die werden z.B. in
Zahnpflege-Kaugummis eingesetzt.
Doch es geht nicht nur um Kalorien,
sondern auch darum,
wie unser Körper
direkt auf Zucker reagiert.
Wann immer wir Zucker, genauer
gesagt, Glukose, zu uns nehmen,
geht diese Glukose
erst mal ins Blut.
Der Blutzucker steigt.
Das ist erst mal nichts schlimmes,
das passiert nach jedem Essen,
aber wenn der Blutzuckerspiegel
dauerhaft erhöht bleibt,
wird es ungesund.
Deshalb schüttet unser Körper
ein Hormon namens Insulin aus.
Insulin sorgt dafür, dass der
Blutzuckerspiegel wieder sinkt.
Je schlechter diese Insulin-Antwort
funktioniert,
also desto höher
der Blutzuckerspiegel,
und je länger er erhöht bleibt,
desto schlechter.
Bei schlechten Blutzuckerwerten kann
eine "Glukoseintoleranz" vorliegen.
D. h., der Körper kommt
nicht so gut mit dem Zucker klar.
Eine Glukoseintoleranz
erhöht das Risiko,
Diabetes Typ zwei
zu entwickeln.
Bei Diabetikern funktioniert diese
Insulin-Antwort gar nicht mehr,
d. h., sie müssen sich nach
dem Essen Insulin spritzen,
um den Blutzucker zu senken.
Deshalb werden Süßstoffe, die
den Blutzuckerspiegel nicht erhöhen,
nicht nur Diabetikern empfohlen,
sondern man verspricht sich auch,
dass Süßstoffe als Zuckerersatz
das Risiko verringern,
Diabetes Typ zwei zu entwickeln.
So die Theorie.
Doch dann:
Schauen wir uns das genauer an.
Hierzu gibt es mehrere Hinweise
aus der Forschung.
Neben einigen Versuchen mit Tieren
gab es diese kleine,
aber sehr interessante
amerikanische Studie.
17 Menschen mit Übergewicht
nahmen hier teil,
man gab allen Teilnehmern
die gleiche Menge Glukose,
um zu beobachten, wie stark
deren Blutzuckerspiegel stieg.
Doch vor diesem
Glukose-Zucker-Schub,
gab man den Leuten
einmal Wasser zu trinken
und einmal Wasser plus Süßstoff,
plus Sucralose.
Und nach Süßstoff plus Glukose
war der Blutzuckerspiegel
der Teilnehmer höher,
als nach Wasser plus Glukose.
Und das ist ziemlich unerhört,
denn eigentlich soll Süßstoff ja
unbeteiligt den Körper passieren.
Doch anscheinend ist es doch
nicht dasselbe, wie nur Wasser.
Also, sehr spannende Ergebnisse,
aber die Studie ist zu klein.
Könnte man so eine Studie nicht
in viel größerem Maßstab
über einen langen Zeitraum
durchführen?
Tja, das ist tatsächlich
ein großes Problem
von Ernährungsforschung.
Nämlich, große Ernährungsstudien
mit Menschen scheitern
an ethischen und/oder
praktischen Gründen.
Man kann nur schlecht kontrollieren,
was Menschen
über einen langen Zeitraum
genau essen.
Das geht z.B., wenn
Menschen in einem Heim leben,
aber Menschen,
die in einem Heim leben,
sind nicht repräsentativ
für die allgemeine Bevölkerung.
Deshalb kann man nur beobachten,
kann sich große Datensätze anschauen
und der Frage nachgehen,
haben Menschen,
die oft Süßstoff konsumieren, auch
häufiger Diabetes oder Übergewicht?
Und die Antwort ist: Ja,
das finden sehr viele Studien.
Aber Vorsicht:
es kann zwar bedeuten,
dass Süßstoff zu Übergewicht führt,
es kann aber auch bedeuten,
dass Menschen mit Übergewicht
häufiger zu Süßstoff greifen.
Was sogar naheliegend ist,
dasselbe gilt auch für Diabetiker.
Deshalb ist bei der Interpretation
von Ernährungsstudien,
egal, zu welchem Lebensmittel,
immer Vorsicht gefragt.
Aber gehen wir der Sache
weiter auf den Grund.
2016 kam diese Studie
an Fruchtfliegen raus.
Gab man den Fruchtfliegen ein paar
Tage lang den Süßstoff Sucralose,
zeigten sie sich anschließend
hungriger.
Sie konsumierten viel mehr Kalorien,
als die Kontrollfliegen,
die normalen Zucker bekamen.
Darüber hinaus wurden sie
hyperaktiver und schliefen weniger.
Ob das ganze auf Menschen
übertragbar ist,
lässt sich noch nicht sagen.
Aber diese Studie zeigt
ganz deutlich:
inert, also unbeteiligt, sind diese
Süßstoffe offensichtlich nicht.
Irgendwas machen sie im Körper.
Nur was?
Die Antwort
könnte diese Studie haben.
Die Forscher beobachteten Mäuse,
die entweder auf einer normalen,
oder auf einer High-fat-Ernährung
waren,
Und sie versetzen das Wasser
der Mäuse entweder mit Glukose,
oder mit Glukose plus Süßstoff.
Sie testeten Aspartam, Saccharin,
und Sucralose.
Und nach elf Wochen
zeigten die Mäuse mit Süßstoff
eine erhöhte Glukoseintoleranz.
Doch das Interessante kommt jetzt.
Der Grund dafür liegt
wahrscheinlich im Darm der Mäuse.
Dort leben nämlich,
genau wie bei uns im Darm,
sehr viele kleine Mikroorganismen,
die Darmflora,
oder auch das Mikrobiom des Darms
genannt.
Und während einer Maus
oder ein Mensch Süßstoffe nicht
an sich verstoffwechselt, springen
die kleinen Herrschaften im Darm
durchaus darauf an.
Denn als die Forscher den Mäusen
Antibiotika gaben,
die die Darmbakterien killen,
verschwand auch
die Glukoseintoleranz.
Außerdem nahmen die Forscher
ein bisschen Mäusekacke
von den Glukose intoleranten Mäusen
und transferierten die
in sterile Labormäuse.
Die sind so gezüchtet, dass sie
gar keine Darmbakterien haben.
Danach wurden diese sterilen Mäuse
auch glukoseintolerant,
das bedeutet, bei diesen Mäusen
führte Süßstoff
zu einer Veränderung
der Darmflora
und das zu schlechteren
Blutzuckerwerten.
Also zu einer schlechteren
Glukosetoleranz.
Tatsächlich weiß man schon länger,
die Darmflora eines Menschen
ist sehr individuell.
Sie besteht aus vielen
verschiedenen Bakterienarten
und die genaue Zusammensetzung
hat großen Einfluss auf Verdauung,
Blutzucker, Insulin-Antwort,
sogar Appetit und Fettspeicherung.
Es fehlen jetzt noch
große Studien mit Menschen,
aber die Forscher
mit den Mäusen von gerade,
haben eine kleine Vorstudie gemacht
mit sieben gesunden Menschen.
Sie gaben diesen sieben
Versuchsteilnehmern eine Woche lang
die maximal empfohlene Dosis
Saccharin.
Nach einer Woche zeigten drei
der Teilnehmer keinen Effekt,
vier Teilnehmer zeigten,
ähnlich wie die Mäuse,
eine verschlechterte
Glukosetoleranz.
Wir wissen aber sicher,
dass man Ernährungsstudien
nie von Tieren direkt
auf Menschen übertragen kann,
Denn wir wissen sicher,
bei uns Menschen ist
das ganze einfach komplizierter.
Einfach kompliziert.
Labormäuse, nicht nur gleich halten
und ernähren,
sie sind auch genetisch gleich,
oder sehr ähnlich.
Das ist sehr hilfreich, wenn man
ganz grundlegende Auswirkungen
herausfinden möchte,
z.B., was passiert, wenn man
Zucker durch Süßstoff ersetzt?
Doch die nächste Frage,
oder die für uns relevante, ist,
inwieweit wirkt sich das
auf unseren Alltag aus?
Denn bei Menschen sind die
Unterschiede bei Ernährung, Umwelt
und genetischen Faktoren so groß,
dass so eine Frage, wie,
Süßstoff ja oder nein?
Nur ein Faktor von so vielen ist.
Und dadurch automatisch
weniger ins Gewicht fällt.
Ins Gewicht fällt, ha!
In diesem sehr aktuellen Paper
wurden die bisherigen Studien
zu Süßstoff und Darmflora
neu bewertet und zusammengefasst.
Hier heißt es: eine Veränderung
der Darmflora durch Süßstoffe
sieht man nur bei Süßstoffmengen,
die so groß sind,
dass sie für uns Menschen und unsere
Ernährung nicht von Bedeutung sind.
Das ist erst mal beruhigend.
Trotzdem kann man nicht
ausschließen, dass auch sehr kleine,
aber dafür langfristige
Veränderungen
nicht doch kritisch sind.
Da bleibt uns derzeit
nichts anderes übrig,
als die Forschung
weiter gespannt zu verfolgen.
Ja, und jetzt, was fange ich
mit diesen Infos an?
So lange die Forschung
noch nicht abgeschlossen ist,
soll ich jetzt Cola light trinken
oder nicht?
Ihr solltet es am besten so halten:
Süßes immer nur in Maßen,
egal ob Zucker oder Süßstoff.
Dafür gibt es, abgesehen von
den gerade genannten Hinweisen,
noch drei weitere gute Gründe:
wer glaubt, dass er sich
mit Cola light,
oder mit zuckerreduzierten
Pudding was Gutes tut,
tappt leicht in die psychologische
Falle des Freifahrtscheins.
Wir scheinen uns geschmacklich
an vieles zu gewöhnen.
Und es gibt sehr viele persönliche
Erfahrungsberichte,
die sagen, je mehr Zucker oder
Süßstoff ich esse,
desto weniger süß empfinde ich Obst
oder andere gesunde Zuckerquellen.
Und Menschen,
die mal Zucker reduzieren,
gibt es ja gerade auf YouTube
sehr viele Selbst-Experimente,
berichten alle, dass
irgendwann der Standard
Schokoriegel aus dem Supermarkt
zu süß schmeckt.
D. h., wenn wir mit Süßstoffen
ständig unsere süß-Rezeptoren
überstrapazieren,
können wir dadurch den Geschmack
und die Wertschätzung
für gesundes süßes Essen verlieren.
Lebensmittel, die stark gesüßt
sind, und vor allem die,
die mit Zuckerersatz,
mit Süßstoffen angeboten werden,
sind meistens extrem nährstoffarm.
Also Ernährungstechnisch gesehen
völlig wertlos. Buchstäblich.
Klassisches Beispiel
sind Softdrinks.
Wenn der Zucker dran ist,
sind das typische leere Kalorien,
so sagt man.
Nur Kalorien, keine Nährstoffe.
Und mit Süßstoffen ist da
nur ein leeres Nichts.
Gesunde Ernährung heißt, gesunde
Nährstoffe zu sich nehmen.
Und die findet man in solchen
Lebensmitteln nicht.
Süßstoffe sind,
nach aktueller Datenlage,
nicht schlimmer als Zucker,
Sie helfen bei der Kalorien-
und Zuckerreduktion, auch,
wenn die Nebenwirkungen, z.B.
Veränderungen der Darmflora
immer noch erforscht werden.
Aber weniger Zucker
ist definitiv gut.
Die meisten von uns, ich
auch, sind weit entfernt
von der offiziellen
Empfehlung der WHO.
Die sagt, pro Tag bitte nicht mehr
als 50 oder besser, 25 g Zucker.
Das ist gar nicht mal so viel.
Und Süßstoffe können dabei helfen,
aber wie gesagt,
noch besser ist es,
ganz zu verzichten und
statt der Cola einfach
ein Glas Wasser trinken.
(aus dem Off) Buuuuh!
Was ist mit euch?
Nehmt ihr gerne mal
ein Light-Produkt,
oder seid ihr
richtige Zuckermonster?
Oder fällt es euch relativ leicht
zu verzichten?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
habt schöne Feiertage
und wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Hm. Okay.
Bäh!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)